Iran's moderate president Hassan rouhani
secured his re-election this morning in
a vote that has major significance for
the country's relationship with the US
and the West Elizabeth Palmer is in
Tehran the capital with the latest
Elizabeth good morning good morning
there'd been some speculation this was
going to be a tight race but in the end
it was a decisive win for Hassan rouhani
he got more than 60% of the vote
turnout was so heavy in yesterday's
election that voting was extended until
midnight after a long hot day that saw
people standing in line for hours to
cast their ballots the winner is the
incumbent president Hassan rouhani whose
promises of liberal reforms appealed
especially to be young during an
unusually fierce campaign rouhani
attacked his main opponent
you know the hardliner and former judge
ever I see he even raised the taboo
subject of Rice's role in the execution
of thousands of opposition members after
the Revolution but rice II did have
strong populist appeal especially among
the poor and less educated who fear
Iran's opening up to the world in the
wake of the nuclear deal mr. Murakami
batana Omri Coy's Ramadan Hodja told us
I voted to stand up to America Israel
and the rest of the unit
by contrast rouhani supporters voted for
more contact with the US and the rest
Parham Bihari is an engineering student
for us the most important thing is the
relationship here on the relations with
other nations life here remains a
struggle for millions thanks in part to
US sanctions rouhani x' priority as he
starts his second term will be to entice
foreign companies to come to iran
bringing money and badly needed jobs but
Anthony Hassan rouhani is going to face
some resistance in Washington so far
anyway the Trump administration has been
talking very tough on Iran Elizabeth
Palmer in Tehran thanks Liz